호르무즈 해업 관련 2주간의 휴전 협상이 드디어 타결이 됐습니다.
자 그런데 함정이 좀 있어요. 어떤 함정이 있는지 뒤에서 얘기를 해보겠습니다.
2주간의 휴전 협상이 극적으로 타결이 되면서 지금 증시가 정말 불기둥을 뿜고 있고요.
코스피가 6%, 코스닥이 4% 이렇게 오르고 있습니다.
유가도 오랜만에 정말 시원하게 떨어져서 100불 이하가 됐어요.
그래서 WTI가 95달러 그리고 브랜트유가 93달러가 됐고요.
트럼프가 어떤 얘기를 했느냐. 한국 시간으로 오전 7시에 그러니까 협상 마감 시한으로부터 1시간 반 전에 트럼프가 자신의 SNS에 글을 올렸습니다.
여러 가지 말들이 있었지만 2주간 이란에 대한 폭격 및 공격을 중단하는 데 동의한다고 했고요.
이란도 호르무즈 해업의 완전하고 즉각적이고 안전한 개방을
한다 이렇게 약속을 했고 이란으로부터 10개항에 대한 제안을 받았고 이것이 협상 실행 가능한 기초라고 판단한다.
이걸로 이제 협상을 해보겠다라고 얘기를 했어요.
그래서 사실 너무 긍정적이죠.
제가 정말 민망할 정도로 몇 시간 전에 영상에서 이게 좀 애매하게 그냥 데드라인만 계속 밀리는 애매한 형태로 지속이 될 거라고 생각을 했는데
결과적으로는 이제 협상 휴전 협상이 타결이 됐습니다.
그래서 역시 단반권입니다.
lag그러면 근데 이게 뭐 단반권인가 진심을 담아서 이야기를 했더니.
단반권이 됐네요.
그래도 틀려도 기분이 좋은, 이렇게 틀려도 기분이 좋은 것 같습니다.
어쨌든 너무 잘 된 거 같고.
다만 이제 걱정되는 부분들이 여전히 존재하긴 해요.
그러니까 트럼프가 생각하는 15개의 요구안과 이란이 생각하는 10개 요구안이 생각보다 첨예하게 다릅니다.
너무 항목들이 많으니까 제가 그런 것들을 다 말씀 드릴 수는 없는데
이게 이제 미국의 요구사항이고
그리고 이것이 이란에 대한 처 반대입니다.
이란의 요구사항입니다.
그런데 이 두 가지 요구사항들 중에서 어떤 것들이 좀 첨예하게 대립이 될까라고 봤을 때는
제가 보기에는 한 세 가지 정도일 것 같아요.
어떤 것들이 좀 첨예하게 미국과 이란이 대립을 할 가능성이 높냐.
첫 번째는 이란에 대한 비공격 보장.
그러니까 이란을 침입하지 않을 보장을 달라라는 거죠.
이란을 공격하지 않을 보장을 달라라고 하는 건데
미국도 받아들이기 어렵겠지만 이스라엘 입장에서는 더더욱 받아들이기 어려울 가능성이 높은 생각보다 쉽지 않을 거라고 저는 생각이 들고요.
두 번째, 우라늄 농축 권리인데 미국과 이란이 갈등하던 포인트가 이거 아니었습니까?
핵을 만든다 안 만든다, 우라늄 농축을 어느 정도 한다.
왜냐하면 우라늄 농축을 하는 기술을 더 나아가서 거기다가 미사일 실고 쏘면 그게 핵무기니까
그래서 이 우라늄 농축에 대한 권리, 이 선을 어느 정도로 서로 합의하고
이게 또 첨예하게 협상의 제약이 될 가능성이 높아 보이고요.
세 번째는 호르무즈 해업에 대한 통제권이에요.
왜냐하면 지금까지 호르무즈 해업에 대한 통제권 사실 없었잖아.
그냥 왔다 갔다, 배들이 왔다 갔다 했는데
이번에 이란은 협상에서 이 호르무즈 해업에 대한 통제권을 아예 나한테 달라.
그리고 나 통행료도 받을 거다.
이렇게 얘기를 하고 있거든요.
그래서 이거에 대해서 미국이 과연 받아들일 것인가.
이게 좀 의문이 좀 있다.
이런 생각이 들고.
그럼에도 불구하고 중국 관세 협상.
이란은 우리가 한번 트럼프가 어떻게 행동하는지 답안지를 본 적이 있죠.
무슨 얘기냐면 중국 관세와 관련된 것도 결국에 되게 흐지부지하게 끝나버렸거든요.
애매하게 관세를 연기한다 이래놓고 그냥 끝났어요.
그래서 저도 비슷한 생각을 기본적으로 갖고 있습니다.
그러니까 이런 상태로 2주간 휴전한다고 하면서 영원히 휴전하는
그런 시나리오도 저는 하나는 생각을 해야 된다고 생각을 하고요.
어떻게 보면 국제사회 입장에서는 나쁘지 않은.
시나리오라고 볼 수가 있겠죠.
자 그리고 이번 휴전 협상에 진짜 함정이 있긴 있습니다.
자 뭐가 있냐.
바로 통행료를 징수하게 됩니다.
호르무즈 해협에 이란이 이제 공식적으로 공식적으로 통행료를 징수하게 될 거고요.
자 200만 달러를 배 한 척 당 받겠다 라고 하고 있고
제가 지난 시트리니 영상 올려드린 거 기억이 나시는지 모르겠는데
사실상 이미 이란은 호르무즈 해협에 대해서 통행료 징수를 하고 있었습니다.
사실상.
하고 있었고 그게 이제 공식화되는 상황이 바로 이 협상의 함정인 것 같아요.
다만 또 뒤집어 보면 한편으로 긍정적이기도 합니다.
왜냐하면 미국 입장에서도 호르무즈 해협에 대해서 통행료를 징수하는 걸 받아들였다는 얘기이기 때문에
어쨌든 휴전했다는 것 자체가 그 얘기니까 휴전에 오케이 했다는 것 자체가 그 얘기니까
어떻게 보면 이대로 장기화될 수도 있겠다 이대로 장기화되는 것도 사실 국제사회 입장에서
엄청나게 최악은 아니잖아요.
최악은 면하는 거니까 나쁘지 않다라는 생각이 일단 들긴 하고요.
자 다만 그러면 실제로 이렇게 호르무즈 해협에 배 한 척 당 200만 달러가 매겨질 때
통행료가 생길 때 어느 정도 유가가 추가적으로 상승할 것인가를 시뮬레이션을 좀 돌려봤어요.
자 제가 돌린 게 아니라 요즘에 인공지능이 좋기 때문에 인공지능 여러 군데에다 물어봤습니다.
그래서 모든 인공지능 언어 모델이 동일하게 말하는 거는
유가가 원가로만 치면 배럴당 1달러에서 3달러 정도 오를 요소라고 합니다.
그래서 이것만 봤을 때는 유가가 엄청나게 많이 오르지는 않아.
왜냐하면 배 한 척 당 들고 다니는 이 기름의 양이 워낙 많으니까
뭐 이거에다가 200만 달러 붙인다고 해도 순수 비용 전가만 한다고 했을 때
배럴당 1에서 3달러인데 문제는 그냥 이걸로 끝나지 않을 거다라는 거죠.
리스크 프리미엄 그러니까 여기 지나갈 때 통행료 받는다는 거 자체가 무섭잖아.
또 언제 봉쇄가 될지도 모르고.
그러다 보니까 리스크 프리미엄도 붙을 것이고 관련돼서 보험료 같은 거
그다음에 또 공급망 전체에도 영향을 주기 때문에
아 이거 싫어서 그럼 뭐 새로운 공급망을 만들고 그럼 또 원가가 올라가고
그럼 우회하는 비용까지 포함을 했을 때
그러면은 한 배럴당 10달러에서 15달러까지 올라갈 수가 있고
그거에 대해서 더 시장이 걱정하는 마음이 커지면
15달러 이상도 평시에 비해서 올라갈 수가 있는 거다라는 게
클로드 엔트로픽 클로드의 시나리오인데
크게 다르지가 않아요.
제가 재미나이도 돌려보고 채찌피티도 돌려봤는데
기본적으로 비슷한 시나리오를 얘기를 합니다.
그래서 한 10달러에서 15달러 정도 유가가 상승할 만한 시나리오로 본다라는 게 결론이었어요.
그래서 시장의 충격은 이 정도로 보는 게 맞을 것 같다.
어느 정도 예측치인 것 같다라고 보고 있고요.
또 한 가지 갈등의 씨앗 그냥 이렇게 다 끝나면 좋은데
AP 뉴스를 좀 보니까 AP 뉴스에서 어떤 얘기가 있었냐.
갈등의 씨앗이 또 하나 보였어요.
별게 아니길 바라는데
어떤 얘기냐면 이란이 자국어로 작성된 10개 항의 휴전안에 대해서는
핵 프로그램에 대해서 우라늄 농축을 수용하겠다라는 문구가 들어가 있었는데
되게 웃긴 게 이란이 외교관 기자들한테 공유한 영어 버전에는
우라늄 농축을 수용한다라는 문구가 빠져 있었다라는 거예요.
그래서 이란어로 된 버전과 영어로 된 버전에
우라늄 농축을 수용하겠다는 문구가 빠져 있었다는 거예요.
우라늄 농축에 대한 문구가 이란어에는 들어가 있고 영어 버전에는 빠져 있는데
그러면 이걸 갖고 또 트럼프가 트집을 잡거나
미국이 트집을 잡으면서 협상이 엎어질 수도 있는 거 아닌가?
아니면 중간에서 협상을 중지하는 사람이 장난을 친 건가?
뭐 이런 생각도 들고
제가 생각해도 우라늄 농축을 생각보다 쉽게 양보할 수가 미국이 없거든요.
그래서 이거를 양보해줬다는 것 자체가 조금 이상한 의아한데
어쨌든 돌아다니는 휴전안에 대해서는
언어마다 다르다라는
그런 AP 뉴스에 기사가 있고
이란의 UN대표부는 이런 질문에 대해서 논평 요청에 응하지 않았다라고 합니다.
그래서 이게 또 하나의 변수가 될 수 있겠다라는 생각이 좀 들었습니다.
그래서 어쨌든 휴전이 시작됐으니까
2주간의 유예 기간을 얻은 느낌인데
또 이렇게 보고 나니까
지난 작년 4월 중국과의 관세협상을 하던 게 데자뷰가 있기도 하고
방금 말씀드린 또 이런 걱정의 씨앗이 있기 때문에
어떻게 될지 또 지켜봐야 할 것 같은데
모르겠습니다.
진짜 너무 어려운 것 같아요.
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고
투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 설명란 고정 댓글 참고 부탁드립니다.
그리고 또 AP 뉴스 관련된 거 제가 링크 달아 놓을 테니까
한번 확인해 보시고 저는 또 돌아오겠습니다.